[Music]
to put the casting in perspective this
would be like if the 2016 version
starred Miranda Lambert and famed
seventies child actor Kristy McNichol
look if red buttons is playing a
character named hoagie the movie is
probably pretty awful just say Disney
hired comedian Charlie Callas to provide
scooby-doo sleep-talking sounds for
Elliott the dragon can you imagine how
stoked the actors playing man with visor
and Eggman were to get their names and
the opening credits basically three
minutes and 15 seconds of opening
credits that are boring fade from
opening credits painting to real film
footage is hilariously unmatched and
uncoordinated entirely it's just
literally a fade between two completely
different types of scenes also
soundstage force is soundstage II what
the actual either Elliot's neck is
getting bigger and smaller as they walk
her feet isn't holding on to anything at
all
also if Pete's just going around on his
back why does Elliot need to make
himself invisible I don't know what's
scarier a cartoon dragon or a floating
red head telling an invisible creature
to hide how do you know that was his
tail that damn it even a standard horror
film has the common courtesy to wait
more than a minute before throwing in
jump scares also that's one way to start
a children's movie with a kid being
stalked by a gang of terrifying adults
with weapons
this kid is being hunted by the discount
Beverly Hillbillies god damn it this is
a fucking musical nobody told me that
it's funny because they want to beat a
child
then explain the agitated yelling and
the gruesome torture you later described
we don't say why you go this is the
first time in cinemasins history I'm
going to pause the movie an email Chris
about how much I hate his ass for
putting this bullshit on the schedule
please hold a moment
do your Chris
[Music]
we later find out we are in Maine which
brings up this question why are these
Appalachian Clampett looking books
living in Maine well this song is
darkest no wonder this kid starts seeing
cartoon dragons after living with these
assholes also are they murders why do
they want him back so bad if they're
gonna kill him choreographed redneck
read that's kind of horrifying beats
dragon the fun family movie about
cannibal Hillbillies out to kill a
mentally ill young boy can't imagine why
this wasn't a hit pretty sure this guy
is wearing an actual civil war huh
convenient sloppy mud pit is convenient
well this is my first viewing of this
movie but I utterly despise it not ten
minutes in mind you kenny loggins
bumpkin must have the strongest neck in
existence in order to support the weight
of his entire body after a fall this
opening scene kind of demonstrates why
this movie should have zero conflict
right dragon knocks asshats into the mud
he and Pete move along repeat as
necessary I mean what am I missing this
movie takes place entirely in the early
1900's so $50 is a lot of money but 50
cents isn't really too hard to swallow
especially if you had $50 to pay in the
first place also these people seem seedy
is why don't they just kidnap a kid if
they want one so bad
this kid is excellent at hiding but he's
also got a dozen ticks by now which he
surely won't know to look for and remove
so basically Lyme disease is inevitable
[Music]
[Applause]
look these people are as terrible at
being guardians of a child as this movie
suggests why would the runaway child
come out of hiding when they yell his
name shouldn't they be super quiet and
yes the movie is also saying that
they're stupid but I'm wondering how
they ever managed to keep this child in
their custody in the first place if they
are this dump moments ago they talked
about how if Pete isn't found they'll
have to do the work on the farm but
they're still singing about murdering
him hi Elliot what the fuck
I'd almost a prefer the dragon stay
invisible to me the entire movie as
opposed to this horse also so who framed
roger rabbit eat your heart out bitches
hi Elliot so you've got a magical dragon
and he's named Elliot sure you don't
want to try again
drogon Falkor toothless I'm starting to
get angry like kill the video for a
second Chris needs to know how upset I
am he asked me to send this bull dude
have you seen this movie I don't think
so I think he just put it on the
schedule and assigned it to me because
there's a remake coming but this is some
Republic dude and the worse it gets the
more I blame your ass just FYI an
asshole introducing the most
anatomically unfortunate dragon that has
ever existed why is the red fruit he
picked off that tree suddenly purple
when animated that's an apple tree not
an apple and plum tree the director said
take a bite of this Apple it'll make you
look like even more of a redheaded
asshole Pete must be talking to the
larger other invisible dragon that is
behind Elliot's left shoulder because he
is definitely not looking at Elliot this
kid tries to Kevin Spacey from seven
murder this dragon through gluttony
[Music]
first of all there's not one left look
around you there are hundreds left also
do we really need to use this moment to
make the Dragons seem compassionate for
letting the boy eat the last Apple even
though he ate most of the other ones
ladies and gentlemen special effects
there's Elliot fart cinnamon and sneeze
butter or anything otherwise this is
just going to be a hot mushy Apple No
in your eyes and you whisper sweet me
kill me also to be songs inside 12
minutes means this movie is my enemy and
I will attempt to kill it are they about
to kiss this movie is the result of one
powerful person's late-night acid trip
that's the only explanation Jesus Christ
I'd rather run laps than finish watching
this thing Pete understands dragon
gibberish you may ask yourself why
doesn't the movie just make the dragon
speak English to which I would respond
everyone knows dragons can't talk don't
be an asshole the hair on his tail
apparently works like fingers and is
strong enough to hold a human boy movie
rips off the song I sing to the condom
on the rare occasion I get to have sex
[Music]
so though was this long supposed to be
in another movie starring adults in love
also pique clearly has never heard an
angel singing but come to think of it
neither am i beat must know something I
don't
I'm counting it as a sin anyway I just
realized I should have taken drugs
before watching this movie I could be
having the time of my life right now hmm
yeah no I didn't know when Elliott's in
the shade he loses color saturation
how the fuck is Elliott flying around
right now you should have to be carried
around like Heimlich the caterpillar
after becoming a butterfly
I'll buy the peak is an orphan slave and
I'll buy that he has an imaginary dragon
but there's no way this kid can read
Elliott not only has the ability to make
parts of himself invisible but also can
create scan around those parts when they
would otherwise be exposing muscles
tendons and veins which would be too
graphic to animate does move you expect
me to believe this sign is in the same
place as the sign because it's not this
guy's trying to sell eggs at the
doorstep of the farmer are you talking
to to save your voice
this guy doesn't yell at this asshole
kid for doing this seeing these giant
dinosaur footprints in the wet pavement
doesn't cause mass hysteria
and the town burned feet for being a
witch and being possessed by a demon and
I'm not a hundred percent sure they'd be
wrong if they thought that where are you
going down to that shop there where they
sell balls of wood and corks pick me up
a couple balls of wood would you sure
this I was telling my dragon about this
head on the side why did you tell him to
become invisible if you're gonna run
around town telling people he exists
she's just now realizing this what
school do you play hooky from this town
has more than one elementary school I
knew it that's just what this town needs
another ignoramus see instead of
inviting this kid to join her class she
calls him stupid and then walks away
giant mumbling Elliott has the sudden
dexterity to lift her skirt and
delicately put her undergarment on a
nail even though there's very little
room for him to be in a position where
you could do this in the first place
hi summer party's a beautiful community
where the Sun always rises and the Sun
always so it's just like every other
fucking place the pink egg guys just
been walking around town gearing up for
this pratfall for the last five minutes
I'm no detective but I normally don't
associate giant three toed lizard foot
prints with a kid's feet no one sees the
kid hide behind these obviously
see-through traps
you spoiled everything hey it's not the
Dragons fault the town is full of
assholes we want to throw a true an
orphan in jail it's funny because he
suffers from debilitating alcoholism not
sure if it's the bad drunk acting or the
bad animation that's causing Mickey
Rooney to look past Elliott but still
talk to him
either way it's a sin Jesus he is drunk
that's not what Elliot looks like at all
definitely battery and possibly assault
these guys really know how to waste some
beer all the barrels around the bar
rotate in place and all these drunk
idiots are able to run on them without
falling
well this bar is ruined hey Elliot
instead of burning your flesh with a hot
stick why don't you just draw lines in
the sand to play tic-tac-toe Elliot
forgot about his invisibility powers do
you Kris no seriously do you have any
idea how much I hate you right now you
don't let me count the ways
he is an asshole who treat the
tick-tack-toe why did you get that
bruise mr. golden I was milking the cow
and I missed the bucket so mr. Cogan hit
me ha convenient expositional picture
these both convenient and expositional
an Pete can a lady write a letter it
looks like Peter has something in common
with the gogans after all yawning right
before falling asleep even though no one
has ever done that in real life cliche
Lampe is still drunk the morning after
his day drinking this guy's already
fixed his fence that Elliott the dragon
accidentally destroyed yesterday dr.
terminus uses a nautical braking system
for land vehicle someone forgot to nail
down these stairs yesterday it's
excellent that these clearly visible
wires attached to the sky we're here to
gingerly toss them into this net
Herman is his assistant is asking him to
keep trying even though the jig is
putting up that worked that's funny
because I'm pretty sure that's the same
bottle your assistant was holding before
that's it Oriental since he got these
potions in Paris the town suddenly
forgets all the terrible things his
previous potions did even though they
were just talking about them 45 seconds
ago I won't send them for using
obviously fake money but I will send
them for using fake money that uses a
mid 20th century design when this movie
takes place in the early 1900s when
dollar coins were much more common
there's no way that liquid gone what the
fuck do I care just so you know this guy
has an Academy Award
also how has no one in this small town
calling out who are you with this guy
government regulation 302 states that no
dragons shall be allowed on the premises
of the United States lighthouses I was
going to send them for this but I looked
it up it checks out
but I'll still send them for having
super weird ass regulations for things
it's been a year not only is there no
way to know if he's lost and drifting he
should most certainly be dead if his
boat didn't sink he would have starved
to death at this point Elliot is warming
his I don't want to know I don't want to
cure anybody here well that works out
because all your stuff is bull right
with degrees from the Royal Medical
College London the diamond einen pizza
in Vienna on the Moulin Rouge in Paris
that's also where Nicole Kidman got her
medical degree this movie teaches
children that drinking is hilarious that
dimly lit lantern is putting on an
impossibly large amount of light ten
pots see what the townspeople actually
love seawater or he assumes they do by
the way it's simple that's racist these
kids are all gaping at nothing
[Music]
Norah's mouth wants to say person but
the track she is singing along to
decided she says stranger
I bet glasses girl over here had that
solo but brown hat Jimmy here wanted it
so bad he could no longer contain his
rage so then he took what he thought was
rightfully his
Stan's claims from the schoolhouse set
fire to the City Hall line so what was
he doing it sitting at his desk - I said
it before I'll say it again how these
rural turn-of-the-century see folk
didn't think this kid is a which is
beyond me I'm starting to think Eliot is
trolling Pete Eliot and poses cartoon
physics on the real world is so many
cures from bits of dragon doc is reading
a book he owns that addresses dragons
like they exist even though he earlier
described them as being an object of
mythology and legend if dragons exist
enough for this book to know what parts
of them to use for cures then why the
hell is he just now discovering this
dragon bits can do all this and this
book knows it then why doesn't this
universe possess an industry around
hunting and harvesting dragons no one
comes outside and tells these assholes
to shut the fuck up movie spends 30
seconds listing different terms for
money and occasionally things you can
buy with money
[Music]
they have literally been saying singing
the same thing for three minutes yo
Chris answer your damn phone I some to
say to you about this Pete's dragon bull
you made me watch stop screening my
calls my medicine that's guaranteed to
bring on puberty two years ahead of time
I've put anyone want that seat does he
speak English
not at all but he seems to have a
limited understanding of English we
grind him up and these two bumbling
idiots plan on doing this all by
themselves
[Music]
uh-huh they are deaf no hilarious
before you were doing chores for people
you hated now you're doing tours for
people you like on the side of the
building please huh
yeah Pete get all that dry paint on that
paint brush on the side of the building
isn't he using gibberish as the hook of
the movies upbeat song cliche a
time-honored tradition all right we've
unevenly spread some crusty dried-up
paint around on the front door now time
to go upstairs by way of this pulley
system and not the stairs after Lampe
opens the lighthouse door the invisible
dragon clearly came behind and shut
because Lampe has to open it in the shop
over a minute of window cleaning book
including some mild a.split oh yeah
these assholes
Oh did someone put a saw movie on while
I wasn't looking this is the second time
I've gotten a pretty strong sexual
assault vibe from this movie so I'm just
gonna add five sins for that being okay
in a Disney movie in 1977
these ultra repetitive songs are the
reason why this movie has a ridiculously
long runtime Eliot blows up their boat
and somehow the occupants of said boat
fly out of it one at a time she has two
Academy Awards maybe put him on a ranch
breed him breed him with what
I don't think doc knows how breeding
works unless he has a girl dragon we
don't know about your only friend
there's a dragon no one still doesn't
believe that Eliot exists even though
she's witnessed most of the mayhem he's
caused in town know also everyone is
terrified of this dragon that has done
nothing more than pull a few Paranormal
Activity coast pranks you you're just
making it up now movie suddenly a
tsunami hits the White House and puts
out the light to help manufacture an
additional conflict I'm glad they lured
Elliot out of the cave before this wave
hit or he would have drowned the gogans
keep Pete's mouth uncovered long enough
for him to squeeze out an admiral ackbar
did they tilt it way up when they
discovered that the docks foot was tying
to the rope or did this just happen for
no reason I guess this whole movie just
happened for no reason also I don't
think the harpoon could even kill Elliot
anyway the only thing that could kill
Elliot is possibly dip or cancer
[Music]
some bullshit on the day of shooting
they realize they didn't give the
townspeople a reason to like Elliott so
they just came up with it at the last
minute movie expects me to believe that
Elliott fit through that door and can
walk up those stairs we've got five
minutes left and she's just now
realizing this Elliott has attracted to
Nora even though he's a different
species we sank in a storm above my head
everything came back to boobie decides
not to write an actual backstory for
this character and just goes with memory
loss because we got four minutes left
right here he'd appreciated if you
thanking yourself the dragon is still
invisible for no goddamn reason it's
amazing how quickly they were able to
repair that lighthouse given that this
happened yesterday please my insights
hurt
[Music]
all of the villagers chased
Alvie the racist dragon into a very cold
and very scary cave it was so dark and
so scary in there that I'll be began to
cry dragon tears there's chatter on
stove
Shou downs I'm not superstitious but I'm
I am a little stiffness 6463 least
already stabbed